[موسيقى]
كما تبعثم الطائره من الداخل ليس بها
اختلافات كبيره عن الطائره التقليديه سوى
فقط الاجنحه التي تسمح لها بالقيام بمهمه
التزود بالوقود في الجو وحينما دائما نسمع
كلمه التزود بالوقود في الجو يتبادر الى
ذهننا التساؤل الاكبر وهو كيف تستطيع
طائره ان تقوم بتزويد طائره اخرى بالوقود
في الجو هذا ما سيجيبنا عليه المهندس
خورخي وهو مهندس اختبارات طائره اي 330 ام
ار تي تي لتزود بالوقود في الجو مهندس
خوخي اولا اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتانيا كيف
تستطيع طائره ام ار تي تي تزويد طائره
اخرى بالوقود في الجو
من اجل اعاده تزويد طائره بالوقود فيجب ان
يتوفر نظامان الاول هو نظام الخرطوم
والمرصاد حيث نرسل الخرطوم من الجناح
وترتبط به الطائره المستلمه عن طريق
المرساد ثم يتم نقل الوقود النظام الثاني
يسمى بومه الذي يقوم المشغل فيها باستخدام
عصا تحكم لايصال ذراع من الطائره المزوده
للوقود الى خزان الطائره المستلمه هذان
هما النظامان المعياريان في كل القوات
الجويه في العالم
بالتاكيد انت حلقت بهذه الطائره من خلال
تحليقك السابق بهذه الطائره ما هي النقطه
الاصعب في عمليه تزويد طائره اخرى بالوقود
في الجو
عمليه التزود بالوقود جوا عمليه معقده
لانها تتطلب اقتراب الطائرتين من بعضهما
وهذه الحركه تحدث في المهام العسكريه ولا
نشهدها بين الطائرات المدنيه ولهذا علينا
تدريب الاشخاص المعتدين على التحليق عن
قرب من الطائرات الاخرى والمشغل يجب ان
يكون متمرسا في توجيه العمليه وقادرا على
التواصل مع الطائره الاخرى لربط المرساد
ولهذا السبب تقوم ايرباص بتطوير نظام
اوتوماتيكي لاعاده التزود بالوقود اسمه اي
ثري ار يستخدم الكاميرات لتحديد موقع
الطائره وتحريك المرصات اوتوماتيكيا
[موسيقى]